Food for thought: Ever counted calories using
nutritional labels?
Well just how accurate are they anyway?
Hi guys, Julia here for DNews.
Food labels are great, they give you an estimate
of how many calories are in a certain food.
But they have a bit of a flaw.
They fail to take into account how cooking
affects food.
So we end up with a system that likely overestimates
the calories available in unprocessed foods
and under estimates the calories in processed
food.
Our current calorie counting system is based
on the Atwater System, which is at least a
hundred years old.
The System standardized the idea of the amount
of energy available in food, 9 calories in
a gram of fat or 4 calories in every gram
of protein.
But this measures the available of energy
in food, not the digestibility.
A calorie is a unit of energy.
It’s technically the amount of energy needed
to heat up a kilogram of water by 1 degree
C. Our body burns calories in food through
metabolizing the carbohydrates and proteins
and what not into smaller molecules our body
can use as energy.
Cooking food changes how many calories are
digestible.
Take potatoes for example, when raw, the sugar
molecules in potatoes are too tightly packed
for our digestive system to handle.
Cooking causes the starches in the potato
to gelatinize.
That process allows us to access the sugars
stored in the starch, so we get MORE calories
out of the cooked potato.
On the other hand, digesting raw food takes
work, a stick of celery might have 10 calories,
but the chewing and digesting burns about
half of them.
All that work means there are fewer calories
for your body to absorb for energy.
But before you go nibbling on an all-carrot
diet, consider this: For our ancestors, cooking
food meant the difference between life and
death.
The invention of a cooked meal might have
changed everything.
Cooking food provided more energy and lead
to human’s bigger brains and bigger babies.
And people who consume an all-raw diet now,
might not be getting enough calories.
Even when eating food packed with nutrients.
Some women on an all-raw diet get irregular
menstrual cycles, a sign of under-nourishment.
On top of that, the type of cooking method
might change the chemistry of food as well
- whether it’s boiled, baked or microwaved.
Not to mention the bacteria in your gut steal
a few of the calories for themselves.[a] So
the exact number of calories you’re getting
is affected by way too many factors for those
labels to be truly accurate.
But while modifications to the Atwater system
have improved it some over the years, there’s
still no real alternative.
So until nutrition scientists come up with
a better calorie counting system take food
labels with a grain of salt.
See what I did there?
Switching gears for a second, I wanna let
you know that tomorrow Trace, Amy and Ian
are gonna be chatting with a real live astronaut
about what it’s like to live and work in
space.
And if you wanna hang out with the space nerds,
be sure to RSVP using the link we’ve got
in the description.
That’s at at 3pm eastern time, noon pacific.
So do you trust nutritional labels?
Do they need to be updated?
Leave your thoughts and comments below and
don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
everyday